[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei Bild der ist der
Ministerpräsident in Hessen und
politisch in den nächsten Monaten der
direkte Gegenspieler der
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
der die will ihn in Hessen vom Thron
kippen im Wahlkampf ja und dieser
Wahlkampf der wird sich dann natürlich
auch um eins drehen um die
flüchtlingslage im Land die richtigen
Fragen jetzt an Boris rein schönen guten
Tag Herr Ministerpräsident stellen Sie
sich vor
einer 1.600 Einwohner Gemeinde und da
sollen jetzt 400 Flüchtlinge in einem
neuen Containerdorf untergebracht werden
wie reagieren sie
ja das ist exakt das Problem mit dem
sehr viele Gemeinden oder auch
Bürgerinnen und Bürger konfrontiert sind
in diesen Wochen und Monaten und meine
Wahrnehmung ist dass die Bundesregierung
überhaupt nicht spürt was vor Ort los
ist und auch nicht nachvollziehen kann
was bei den Menschen in ihnen vorgeht
und ich glaube das ist halt das wo die
Bundesregierung lernen muss dass sie
anders umgehen muss mit der
migrationsbewegung die wir derzeit haben
weil wir natürlich eine große
willkommensbereitschaft haben wir haben
eine große Willkommenskultur bei
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern aber man muss
natürlich aufpassen dass man diese
Solidarität nicht überstrapaziert und
deswegen wollte ich noch mal ganz
praktisch in einen solchen Ort reingehen
das ist ja die Frage die sich jetzt ganz
konkret in vielen Gemeinden stellt das
ist jetzt das Beispiel aus der Gemeinde
Upahl das ist zugegeben von ihnen in
Hessen relativ weit weg in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern aber das ist ein
1600 Einwohner Dorf da sollten jetzt 400
ja Container entstehen 400 Menschen in
Containern in diesem Dörfchen unter
gebracht werden wenn sie da leben würden
wie würden Sie reagieren
naja also zunächst einmal ist glaube ich
auch bei mir und bei allen anderen eine
enorme Bereitschaft vorhanden
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus anderen
Ländern aufzunehmen die verfolgt sind
die Not sind die Hilfe brauchen das ist
bei uns eine große Tradition und so ist
es auch bei mir selbst aber die Frage
ist immer wie lange kann sowas gut gehen
und wie lange kann man damit umgehen ja
die willkommensbereitschaft die oder
Willkommenskultur die will ich gar nicht
zerreden natürlich gibt es ausgebreitete
Arme und die werden dann manchmal aber
ein bisschen weniger ausgebreitet wenn
sich das direkt vor der Haustür abspielt
deswegen noch mal die Frage wenn das ihr
Dorf wäre sie haben selber auch Familie
würden sie versuchen dieses
Containerdorf zu verhindern
nein ich würde nicht versuchen das
Containerdorf zu verhindern sondern ich
würde versuchen
zu integrieren ich würde versuchen Hilfe
anzubieten ich würde versuchen so wie
wir das ja auch bei uns in meiner
Heimatstadt in Frankfurt gemacht haben
bei den Ukrainerinnen die gekommen sind
Unterstützung anzubieten das ist glaube
ich das was Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
auch ich persönlich tun möchten und auch
tun aber wie gesagt die Frage ist
einfach wie lange kann sowas gut gehen
immer mehr Menschen geht aber auf die
Straße und protestieren dann auch gar
nicht in diesen kleinen Gemeinden werde
auf die Straße geht ist der dann
fremdenfeindlich
das kommt ganz darauf an ich glaube man
muss sich das im Einzelnen und auch sehr
konkret anschauen wir haben in
Deutschland einen Grundrecht und dieses
Grundrechte ist doch vollkommen
eindeutig jeder kann zu allem was ihnen
stört oder was ihnen betrifft oder was
ihm auch Sorge bereitet demonstrieren
gehen das kommt immer darauf an was man
dort sagt wie man es sagt wie solche
Demonstrationen vonstatten gehen das ist
glaube ich die ausschlaggebende Frage am
Ende
gerade schon gesagt es gibt immer mehr
immer an mehreren Orten mittlerweile
Protest auch der Straße dort wo neue
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte entstehen sollen
oder auch vor den Rathäusern wie ernst
nehmen Sie diesen Protest
ich nehme den Protest sehr ernst und ich
nehme natürlich auch die Sorgen von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sehr ernst ich
bekomme tagtäglich natürlich auch vor
Ort mit was vor Ort los ist ich bekomme
Schreiben von Landräten von
Bürgermeister die spreche mit Landräten
und Bürgermeister die spreche auch mit
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern vor Ort und die
Menschen haben einfach die Sorge
überfordert zu werden und deswegen ist
der Bund dringend aufgefordert zu
handeln und das auch wahrzunehmen
anzuerkennen was geleistet wird aber
eben auch im Migration und Zuzug zu
steuern und auch zu begrenzen das ist
das was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger von
ihrer Bundesregierung erwarten denn der
Schlüssel für Steuerung und Begrenzung
von Migration und Zuwanderung die
ausschließlich in Berlin aber mein
Eindruck ist das die in Berlin den Kopf
einfach in den Sand stecken er sich
gerade in Zeichen davon diese Menschen
dort in den Gemeinden auch bei ihnen in
Hessen dann an der Bergstraße im
Odenwald wo besonders viele auch in
Zelten mittlerweile untergebracht sind
oder auch in Container Städten eben dass
man diese Menschen ernst nimmt
gleichzeitig ungefähr im Moment 1.000
weitere Flüchtlinge zu uns kommen nach
Deutschland pro Tag
ja es ist wichtig dass man das ernst
nimmt es ist wichtig dass man darauf
eingeht das ist wichtig dass man mit den
Menschen redet und dass wir natürlich
auch dann diejenigen die zu uns kommen
erst kommen Sie zu uns in die
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung das sind
Einrichtungen des Landes und dann werden
sie weiter verwiesen an die kommunale
Familie also das heißt an Städte
Gemeinden und Landkreise und ich muss
sagen die erledigen eine großartige
Aufgabe und eine großartige Arbeit in
diesen Tagen in diesen Wochen das ist
wirklich stark was dort geleistet wird
und das muss auch anerkannt werden und
in den Städten und in den Gemeinden
versuchen die Bürgermeister und die
Landräte natürlich auch wirklich dann
die Verteilung sehr gerechte und sehr
gleichmäßig vorzunehmen das eine zu
große Belastung von so wie sie es
beispielsweise eben genannt haben 1600
Einwohner 400 Flüchtlinge das eine
solche Unwucht nicht eintritt jetzt
schlagen die Landräte ja flächendecken
dem Grunde Alarm es gibt erste
Bürgermeister die sagen das hat ja alles
keinen Sinn mehr ich werde sowieso nicht
gehört ich hör auf ich leg mein
ehrenamtliches Amt jetzt nieder das
bringt hier nichts mehr ich will auch
dafür nicht mehr gerade stehen müssen
für das was woanders versemmelt wird
heißt das wir brauchen im Moment ein
Aufnahme Stopp
das ist eine ich würde mal sagen fast
theoretische Frage ob sein Aufnahmestopp
geben wird das ist ja so einfach nicht
zu regeln ich plädiere sehr dafür
Migration und Zuwanderung zu steuern und
zu begrenzen und die Möglichkeiten hat
nur Berlin und insbesondere plädiere ich
sehr dafür jetzt endlich die
angekündigte rückführungsoffensive wir
im Koalitionsvertrag dieser Koalition
dieser Ampelkoalition steht diese
rückführungsoffensive auch endlich
umzusetzen sie müssen sich das
vorstellen die haben fast eineinhalb
Jahre gebraucht um überhaupt einen
rückführungsbeauftragten zu finden dann
wird ein hilfloser Gipfel nach dem
anderen veranstaltet und es kommt gar
nichts mehr raus außer einem Dashboard
sie müssen sich das vorstellen die Leute
haben Sorgen und Nöte vor Ort und am
Ende kommt ein Dashboard raus ich
verstehe dass der Landkreistag dass der
Städtetag dass die alle auf den
Barrikaden sind und die unterstützen Sie
auch bei ihrem Protest denn die
Bundesregierung muss handeln der
Bundeskanzler muss das Thema endlich zu
Chefsache machen sie tun so als hätten
sie mit nichts zu tun aber sie sind
diejenigen die im Grunde genommen die
Organisation in der Hand haben die CDU
ja lange genug auch regiert und wir
hatten Union CSU Bundesinnenminister da
hat das mit der Abschiebung jetzt auch
nicht grandios viel besser funktioniert
wie klappt das denn im Moment in Hessen
mit der Abschiebung wir sind da die
Zahlen
sie müssen sich vorstellen also wir
hatten ja 2015 die große
Flüchtlingswelle und jetzt ist 2023 also
das heißt es hätte längste die Vorarbeit
geleistet werden können das in den
Herkunftsländern die Voraussetzungen
geschaffen werden definitiv aber wir
haben viele vielleicht Probleme für alle
wie viele Menschen leben bei ihnen in
Hessen im Land in Frankfurt und so
weiter die eigentlich gar nicht da sein
dürften
wir haben eine gesamtschutzquote von 56%
und das bedeutet dass fast die Hälfte
eigentlich zurückgeschoben werden müsste
aber das funktioniert deswegen nicht wir
würden uns auch gerne machen als Land
funktioniert nur deswegen nicht weil die
Voraussetzungen den Herkunftsländer
nicht geschaffen worden sind und jedes
Land in der Welt ist völkerrechtlich
dazu verpflichtet seine Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wieder zurückzunehmen wenn sie
nicht irgendwo anders einen
Aufenthaltstitel ein Recht zur
Aufenthalt bekommen
ungefähr in Hessen die eigentlich gar
nicht da sein dürfen
so ist das ganz genauso ist das und wie
gesagt das würde uns die Möglichkeiten
schaffen diejenigen die wirklich in Not
sind auch hier unterzubringen und ihnen
beispielsweise auch Möglichkeiten zu
schaffen in die Schule zu gehen oder in
Kindergärten zu gehen und solange das
Problem nicht gelöst ist wird das ganz
große Problem eben weiterhin bestehen
bleiben und deswegen das ist die Aufgabe
der Bundesregierung da passiert aber
rein gar nichts das heißt für die 18.000
die bei ihnen im Land leben sagen sie da
kann ich nichts machen das ist Frau
Felser
ja also wir würden wie gesagt wir sind
für die Rückführungen zuständig das ist
doch gar keine Frage in den Ländern wenn
aber die Voraussetzungen in den Ländern
in die zurückgeführt werden muss wenn
die nicht geschaffen sind dann
funktioniert das ganze System nicht die
eine Aufgabe ist unsere die andere
Aufgabe ist jedes Bundes das wollen wir
sehr schön auseinanderhalten und der
Bund erledigt seine Hausaufgaben nicht
und deswegen sind wir die wir am unteren
Ende ja sozusagen stehen gehindert
zurückzuführen und ich sage Ihnen auch
Methoden die natürlich durchaus wirksam
werden könnten um zurückzuführen in den
Herkunftsländern muss beispielsweise auf
diplomatischen Wege dafür gesorgt werden
es muss über das Instrumentes dafür
gesorgt werden es muss über das
Instrument auch der Entwicklungshilfe
dafür gesorgt werden und es gibt noch
ein Instrument was ein ganz wichtiges
Instrument ist das eine restriktive Visa
Politik und die Bundesregierung hat auf
dem europäischen Gipfel mit dem
Europäischen Rat genau dieses Instrument
abgelehnt ich frage mich wie kommt man
dazu solche Instrumente abzunehmen das
ist im übrigen auch gegenüber den
Ländern der EU den europäischen Partnern
unfair die genau diese Instrumente
anwenden wollen und deswegen auch hier
muss schnell etwas passieren jetzt ist
ja ganz klar und das zeigen die letzten
Jahre wenn die Menschen einmal hier sind
dann kriegt man die fast nicht mehr weg
oder sie kommen sogar nach der
Abschiebung wieder das haben ja die
neuen Zahlen auch ostfäser sind
Ministerium gezeigt mittlerweile
tausende nach Deutschland gekommen die
schon mal abgeschoben waren also auch
das eine Zahl des Versagens der
deutschen Flüchtlingspolitik also Strich
runter Rückführung das wird nicht
funktionieren äh Zukunft das heißt man
wird darauf schauen müssen dass
tatsächlich nur diejenigen kommen die
man dann auch haben möchte und nicht
alle die illegal einreisen und mal
wieder schwer loswerden muss das heißt
sie haben vom steuern und begrenzen
gesprochen wie wollen sie es schaffen
es gibt verschiedene Methoden das zu
schaffen also zunächst einmal muss
natürlich die grenzinfrastruktur in die
Lage versetzt werden auch dafür zu
sorgen dass Leute nicht einfach
illegal einwandern das heißt höhere
Zäune mehr Zäune Mauer und was heißt das
konkret mehr Zäune Zäune Mauer das heißt
dass das heißt das konkret das heißt das
ganz konkret in der Tat das ist ja auch
etwas wofür die Europäische Kommission
Gelder zur Verfügung stellt und es gibt
auch Länder in Europa die entsprechende
genau das tun es gibt aber noch andere
Möglichkeiten das zu tun beispielsweise
weitaus mehr Fahndungen
auszuschreiben in den Grenzgebieten
beispielsweise eben gegen
Menschenhändler gegen Schlepper das
Schlepper Unwesen ist ja ein großer Teil
dieser Problematik und es gibt natürlich
auch noch einen weiteren Schritt den die
Koalition im übrigen auch in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag stehen hat das sind
die Aufnahmeeinrichtungen in
Drittstaaten auch das muss endlich
umgesetzt werden wir haben bei dieser
Koalition ja ein Zyklus mit etwas
angekündigt dann wird groß gestritten
und dann gibt es Stillstand und das ist
in der Flüchtlingspolitik ein großes
Problem und er weiß ich sag ihnen was
noch dazu kommt jetzt wird alles
miteinander vermischt sie vermischen
Asyl und Zuwanderung diese Zuwanderung
über die wir gerade sprechen mit
qualifizierter Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt das ist eine unstarthafte
Vermischung der Dinge und das ist auch
gefährlich und es kommt noch was dazu
jetzt wollen sie ja sogar noch das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht in einer Art
und Weise
schaffen Anreize setzen nach Deutschland
sucht so ist es sind weitere Anreise
Anreize nach Deutschland zu kommen ist
ein ganz gefährlicher Cocktail den sie
hier zusammen mixen und es passt jetzt
gerade zu dieser Zeit exakt eben nicht
ich habe das Gefühl in Berlin sind sie
vollkommen taub für die Probleme der
Menschen vor Ort mit dem was sie gerade
geschildert haben wie stark würden sie
aktuell die Flüchtlingszahlen begrenzen
können steuern können
ich glaube dass wir mit den Maßnahmen
die ich eben angesprochen habe die
natürlich längst hätten anlaufen müssen
dass wir mit diesen Maßnahmen jedenfalls
dafür sorgen können dass die Menschen
die zu uns kommen und die wirkliche Not
sind wir haben eine asylgrundrecht das
eben genau diesen Menschen geholfen
werden kann und das ist ja im Grunde
genommen ein Zweiklang Humanität aber
auch Ordnung
man muss ja meine Idee haben im Moment
kennen wir die Zahlen derer die zu uns
kommen und die sind eben so rasant
gestiegen in den vergangenen Monaten das
heißt mit den Maßnahmen starke
Außengrenzen Schutz sie haben auch Zäune
Mauern angesprochen schärfere Kontrollen
in den Grenzgebieten wie weit würden Sie
die Zahlen runterkriegen
also ob es Zäune und Mauern sind das ist
ja etwas was am Ende dann auch vor Ort
von den zuständigen Ländern entschieden
werden muss das kann man hier nicht aus
Hessen heraus empfehlen oder entscheiden
das muss vor Ort entschieden werden wie
das geschieht und wie eine
Grenzsicherung sinnvollerweise
vorgenommen wird das ist nichts wo ich
Ratschläge erteile aber da gibt es
natürlich Methoden und dazu gibt es
natürlich auch Experten die genau wissen
wie das zu funktionieren hat und da
gibt's ja auch in Europa gute Beispiele
wieder zu funktionieren hat ich würde
mir sehr wünschen dass die
Bundesregierung auf europäischer Ebene
sich viel stärker für Lösungen einsetzt
und nicht vorstellen die Optionen aus
der Hand gibt so wie wir das in den
letzten Monaten erlebt haben und das
bedeutet und ich sag das noch mal der
Bundeskanzler muss dieses Thema endlich
zu chefsachen machen sondern werden wir
in den Ländern überfordert aber wie weit
würde man die Zahl runterkriegen also
wir haben ja ähm erinnern uns alle
Diskussion über die Obergrenze geführt
über Monate über Jahre gerade zu und man
hat dann diese 200.000 irgendwann mal
fest geschrieben ja längst nicht mehr
geht wie weit würden Sie die aktuellen
Zahlen runterkriegen
ich kann Ihnen das gar nicht konkret
sagen Sie haben ja selbst die Zahl
gesagt derer die im Grunde genommen aus
Hessen wieder zurückgeführt werden
müssten das ist ja schon eine enorme
Anzahl ne und wenn Sie sich anschauen
die gesamtschutzquote von 56 Prozent
dann können Sie ungefähr davon ausgehen
dass wir von einer Reduzierung um etwas
weniger als die Hälfte oder dass wir
etwas dass wir um eine Reduzierung
sprechen oder über eine Reduzierung
sprechen um etwas weniger als die Hälfte
das ist das was natürlich vor Ort enorm
helfen würde ja das ist schon meine
Hausnummer also die Flüchtlingszahlen
knapp halbieren etwa nach all dem was
sie gestern gerade eben beschrieben
haben und was noch nicht passiert ist in
den vergangenen Monaten und Jahren
würden Sie sagen die
flüchtlingsministerin die
Innenministerin hat die flüchtlingslage
im Griff
also ich kann nur sagen die
Bundesregierung hat die Situation nicht
im Griff und das ist eine gesamte
Aufgabe für die gesamte Bundesregierung
und nochmal am Ende ist die
Bundesregierung oder wird die
Bundesregierung verantwortlich vertreten
vom Bundeskanzler und vom Bundeskanzler
hören wir zu dem Thema eigentlich gar
nichts
ein viel diskutiertes Thema in der
Bevölkerung ist die Zahl von
beispielsweise Messerattacken von Gewalt
Delikten welchen Zusammenhang sehen Sie
aktuell von den hohen Flüchtlingszahlen
zu denen ja vor allen Dingen zunehmenden
messerangriffen zu diesen Gewaltdelikten
im Land auch zu Sexualdelikten
also ich würde das Thema Messerattacken
und Sexualdelikte nicht mit dem Thema
Zuwanderung und Migration vermischen ich
glaube dass das auch gefährlich wäre ein
solchen Zusammenhang herzustellen ich
kann nur sagen ganz allgemein dass wir
mit allen polizeilichen Mitteln gegen
diese im Attacken und gegen diese
Straftaten vorgehen müssen in Hessen
müssen Sie sehen haben wir in den
vergangenen Jahren den Haushalt von 800
Millionen auf 2 Milliarden bei der
Polizei gesteigert um die Polizei
wirklich entsprechend auch dann in die
Lage zu versetzen mit solchen Straftaten
umzugehen wir werden in den nächsten
Jahren 16.000 Polizistinnen Polizisten
in Hessen haben die größte Anzahl die
ist jemals gegeben hat in Hessen das ist
glaube ich der richtige Ansatzpunkt ich
würde aber das Thema Zuwanderung nicht
vermischen mit Straftaten wie
beispielsweise Sexualdelikte oder
Messerattacken auch nicht wenn das die
Statistik so eindeutig sagt bei
Messerattacken das wundert mich ein
bisschen da sie auch zuvor Innenminister
in Hessen waren herein und
wir alle haben jetzt zuletzt die Tat aus
Brock steht die steckt noch in den in
bei uns in den Knochen das heißt sie
sehen wirklich keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen denen die zu uns gekommen sind
und zu steigenden Zahlen vor allen
Dingen eben bei diesen speziellen Taten
den messerangriffen
und ich sage nur dass es gefährlich ist
die Dinge miteinander zu vermischen und
ich sage nur sehr gefährlich ist ein
solchen Zusammenhang herzustellen aber
das muss man sich wirklich nicht da muss
ich noch mal ganz kurz dazwischen gehen
ist es nicht gefährlich den Zusammenhang
nicht zu sehen es sagt doch niemand dass
jeder Flüchtling der zu uns gekommen ist
das sind mittlerweile hunderttausende
das sind 1,3 Millionen im vergangenen
Jahr jeder dieser Männer und Frauen
würde zum Messer greifen das wäre gerade
zu absurd aber ein Zusammenhang in
dieser Lage nicht zu sehen das ist doch
gefährlich
nein also das ist genau der Punkt und
das gilt für die gesamte Debatte wir
sollten hier nichts weg schweigen wir
sollten auch nicht versuchen die Dinge
weg zu nur schön sondern wir sollten
sehr klar über die Situation sprechen
denn alles andere wird natürlich ein
Konjunkturprogramm für radikale Parteien
sein und deswegen über die Lage zu
sprechen ist richtig aber das wichtigste
ist Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und deswegen
rate ich sehr davon ab wie Zusammenhänge
herzustellen wenn Sie nicht da sind aber
reden müssen wir über Sie und wir müssen
Sie natürlich auch bekämpfen solche
entsprechenden Entwickler sie haben
gerade gesagt Sie wollen da keinen
gesamt Zusammenhang sehen bei diesem
Thema also das ist ja ein Weg nuscheln
eigentlich der Realität in diesem Fall
nein nein also ich möchte da gar nichts
wegnuscheln sondern ich sage nur wir
müssen uns so aufstellen dass solche
Straftaten entweder ganz verhindert
werden oder dass solche Straftaten
insbesondere dann auch geahndet werden
und da sehe ich das Hessen wirklich in
der Spitzengruppe der deutschen Länder
marschiert wir haben eine
Aufklärungsquote von über 60% wir hatten
mal eine Aufklärungsquote 1997 bei 44%,
also der entwickelt sich schon sehr viel
und wir nehmen das sehr ernst hier in
Essen sie haben vor kurzem auch gesagt
die Flüchtlingspolitik die dürfe kein
Wahlkampf Thema werden warum nicht
nein wenn ich sage das darf kein
Wahlkampfthema werden dann sage ich
damit dass das nicht das bestimmende
Thema eines Wahlkampfes ist das wird
natürlich immer eine Rolle spielen wie
wir auch in dieser Zeit sehen aber wir
haben so viele andere Themen die wichtig
sind in einem Bundesland nehmen sie die
Schule nehmen Sie die Hochschulen nehmen
Sie Fachkräfte die wir brauchen nehmen
sie den ganzen Bereich der
Verkehrspolitik also das sind alles
Themen die bei uns eine große Rolle
spielen oder auch das Thema Innenpolitik
das Thema nur oder das Thema Migration
alleine im Wahlkampf zu diskutieren und
dem Wahlkampf auch zu verhandeln das
glaube ich das würde der gesamten Lager
nicht gerecht nee aber das haben sie
auch nicht gesagt Sie haben allerdings
gesagt dass das Flüchtlingspolitik Thema
ich habe mir das Zitat nochmal
aufgeschrieben kein Wahlkampf Thema
werden dürfen sie im ZDF gesagt jetzt
haben sie die bundesinnenministerin
sozusagen vor sich treten direkt gegen
die an sie haben gerade das Versagen
geschildert was dort liegt und sie sagen
dann die die Flüchtlingspolitik dürfen
kein Wahlkampf Thema werden das wird man
in einigen Regionen bei ihm im Landkarte
zu als absurd empfinden oder
nein also die Flüchtlingspolitik ist für
uns kein Thema was wir ausschließlich in
einem Wahlkampf führen dass wir in
Hessen über Flüchtlingspolitik sprechen
und dass wir natürlich mit der
Bundesregierung auch darum ringen das
ist besser wird das ist doch vollkommen
klar das liegt doch auf der Hand unter
lasse ich mir auch den Mund nicht
verbieten
ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch der
Ministerpräsident von Hessen Boris rein
war danke die richtigen Fragen danke
[Musik]